I bet you never thought
you'd see a Lamborghini
going off-road
in the Mojave Desert.
Well, the Lamborghini Huracán Sterrato
is out to change that.
Here we are out in
Joshua Tree, California.
It's about an hour east of Palm Springs,
so we're way out in
the middle of nowhere
with a Lamborghini,
if you can imagine it.
The Lamborghini Huracán Sterrato.
This is the off-road version
and it's also the end of an era
because it's the last V10
internal combustion engine
that Lamborghini will ever make.
So it's kind of a big deal.
It's also been a long time coming.
We saw early versions of this car in 2019,
it's finally here.
The base price is $273,000.
I hear it's going to
be really fun to drive.
I can't wait to go try it.
Have you ever been on this track?
No, never. This is completely new.
With brutalist undertones
and a low seating position
this Sterrato comes with a
601-horsepower, V-10 engine
and 413 lb-ft of torque.
It has all-wheel drive
a 0-60 miles per hour sprint time of 3.4 seconds
and a top speed of 161 miles per hour.
Now, don't feel bad
if you're a little skeptical
about this $273,000 supercar.
I was too.
Lamborghini has no record
of success in off-road rallies
in the 60 years since
the brand roared to life.
But that hasn't stopped the brand
from jumping into the off-road mix.
I spoke with Lamborghini
head of design Mitja Borkert
about what makes the Sterrato different
from a normal Huracán.
Our design DNA is about
the single center silhouette.
You can always tell a Lamborghini
in front of you with the inclined windows.
Every car of Lamborghini,
that's my mission,
has to have this character.
So for the customer it
is clear what is the car.
So we took it in a higher position.
We have a slightly longer wheelbase.
We have bigger wheels.
More important,
of course, the rallycross wheels.
We added the cladding,
we kept it quite rough
because we wanted to give this
tough and rugged feeling.
It's the everyday super sports car,
you don't need to care,
you just drive.
It's the car that is your
partner for any adventure.
It's unbelievable
what the car can do.
Yeah.
Unbelievable.
I was driving this thing harder
than I drove the Rivian truck,
rougher than I drove a Porsche 911
or a Land Rover in the sand dunes.
I came out of the car
grinning from ear to ear.
Wow.
But now I wanted to see how it did on the pavement.
Passing by the Joshua trees
and desert dry hills
the Sterrato just cruises.
Man, it's pretty fun.
It's pretty great to go directly
from the dirt onto an asphalt surface.
And I have to say,
driving in Joshua Tree
is the perfect way to explore
both sides of the car.
The Huracán Sterrato
has three main driving modes,
Strada, Sport and Rally.
Now, Rally is the one that we used
when we were going off-road.
That's where everything super loose,
very minimal stability control,
basically just the anti-lock braking system is on.
Now we're in sport mode,
which is a more generalized mode.
It's perfect for driving some of these
back roads in Joshua Tree.
Lamborghini is going to be introducing
more and more hybrids.
We've already seen the Revuelto
and we will soon see
hybrid versions of the Urus as well.
So this really is, in a way,
the end of an era for Lamborghini.
The last V10 with an internal combustion engine
and it's pretty cool
to be able to drive it.
My take, the Huracán Sterrato
is a joyful ode to the
contrarian nature of Lamborghini.
Lamborghini is making
just 1,499 of them,
deliveries begin this summer.